getting excited i'm getting damned
i'm getting wrapped up
i'm george moats and i know hamburgers
today we're outside of the burger
scholar headquarters as you can see
because i'm in los angeles for some
burger related business but guess who
else is also in los angeles at the same
time are you ready for this
we have to be over here
you're gonna
get ready for this
me
i'm here
you're probably figuring this out very
quickly why he's here and why we are set
up here with burger stuff
that's right it's the canadian burger
episode let's do this bombasher hello
i'm as canadian as it gets george you
are my grandfather was a mountain my
mother is a blue noser
you know a blue
my family came to lockport nova scotia
in 1637 from normandy okay we're the
original acadians that makes you
officially a canuck i'm whatever you
need me to be george i need you to be
our canadian expert because i mean i
could have
i could have chosen anyway no um you
couldn't have chosen anyone i happen to
be here george who better i happen to be
here that's the best it can get okay so
i know everything about cheeseburgers
not as much as you but everything else
but you know things about canadian
burgers maybe
i didn't realize it's not starting
research there are many different types
of regional canadian burgers now in the
us there are so many regional american
burgers so many i mean hundreds and
hundreds see i don't know anything
about regional really not really i'm not
a historian i'm not a fax guy i'm a
moment guys i'm gonna throw a couple
places out there you ready okay how
about the saskatoon rink burger
saskatoon rink burger sounds delicious
you know what it is no idea i don't love
going to the tomb ask a tune shout out
to you guys yes the baron burger chain
the baron burger chain alberta no i've
alberta don't know them how about sal's
big nip sal's big nip sounds off
collar
um i don't know yeah they started making
burgers they decided that they didn't
want to call them burgers they want to
call them nips next let's go let's go
grab these chips i don't know forget
those though we're not making any of
those we're going to make two very
specific
regional canadian favorites icons ready
for this one yeah the winnipeg fat boy
you know it i love winter peg okay and i
love fat boys and the dick and
cheeseburger see the dick and
cheeseburger he knows
my nipples got hard the [ __ ] burger
yeah i think aesthetically
the coolest burger in our country these
thin
little burgers like like pancakes yeah
it was one of those like beautiful
childhood memories going back to
[ __ ] is like an incredible thing
let's do this canada here we come
yeah
so the fat boy yeah the pride of
winnipeg was event in the early 50s a
couple of greek guys came in george and
gus skorus it sounds
right sounds greek right home is great
first it was called the lotta burger
okay then it was called the big boy yeah
then it was called the fat boy fat boy
there you go let's make it okay okay so
so simple yeah
i use parchment paper because i like the
hand smash now it's a pretty thick
burger it's a fat boy it's a fat boy and
what do you use it here just like beef
just boom this is cheese yeah this is
chopped straight
yep that's it
i call that hand smashing hand smashing
yes
you're hand padding
there you go smashing here we go ready
oh amazing look at that that's a big
that's a big guy definitely gonna lose
boom
we need some salt here yeah i know it's
sugar sugar
no salt
sugar what makes a fat boy fat boy what
i understand is the special chili chili
they love it chili out there
now this is not just any kind of chili
though this is the classic coney sauce
the idea of coney sauce was that or any
kind of chili sauce was that it was
yesterday's meat that was made into
chili
and so it became something that went on
a hamburger i learned it so much yeah i
don't think they toast their [ __ ]
buns there which is crazy right there's
a lot of neglect on the bun
in canada slices of tomato here's spice
and tomato
with my hand
this is a perfect mealy hot house tomato
look at that that one's so good
cheese on we're putting cheese on here
now pretty sure there's cheese on there
i don't know i would hope so i just like
cheese on it anyways i don't like
hamburgers do you want more water on
here do you want it you want to stand
out
don't want to stand up where's the
where's the bottle of water ahead
i got here
oh thank you
you told me when
we were
spill it
don't smell the [ __ ] dog food i was
supposed to oh you were doing that is
that how you cut it out that's nice
that's how they would do it yeah
greek guys
it's so great already it's nice look at
the crust on it yeah that's good and you
call that the malaria
i call it crust crust okay malaria
effect
everyone's all really excited about that
so the next step is on top of that there
we go that goes up hot topic literally
ladle this on
thank you chef yes
ladle on some chicken oh
oh it's okay it's a lotta
it's gonna be like that a lot of burger
now a diced onion you need some onion
not grated that on top of there
somewhere it's a dill spirit right here
on top of that goes oh that's just right
made to right
made to fall apart exactly i like that
then the architect of this burger
wasn't thinking about mouth feel okay
and then mustard you need the mustard
george probably almost lettuce
[Applause]
that cuts it
this looks insane no if you look at any
photo on the internet that's exactly
what it [ __ ] looks like yes
and then you put a dry
cold bun on top
i don't think they toast they why would
they you might why would you want to
toast something just for fun and then
you make a baseball out of it
wow wow
get your jaw in that
there you go oh watch out this is
[ __ ] dude give a squeeze
shake it off a bit you gotta shake it
off you know
hello winnipeg
right
is that where you're at winnipeg right
right
oh kind of incredible
it's really good my job is to make sure
it's as accurate as possible and if
anybody's watching this
and they're saying themselves this guy
is an american what the hell do you know
about canadian burgers we actually did
we just made the sweets
i made a winnipeg fat boy right there
and by the way it's been approved by a
canadian
woohoo and winnipeg
a little bit that's good enough
you've done right
on the next a dick and cheeseburger your
favorite
oh we're filming yeah we're rolling
right perfect yeah i know we were
talking about george yes the dick is
i've already told my childhood story all
about the dick and burger i think
[ __ ] is one of the most i i should
say like the
most iconic fast food
burger shop okay right they wear the
paper hats still yeah it's like holding
on to real tradition of when it started
yeah such a lovely place to go with your
family
dick anne yeah okay yeah two people one
person two people dick and nan
opened in 1954 by dominic potenza dick
potenza dickie
he was an american guy he brought his
idea of an american burger to montreal
with his montreal wife and buns and
burgers burgers over 60 years old it's
over 60 years old and guess what still
holds true and it's still there i'm
going to try to make you a burger that
you've already had that i've never had
before i love this game it's a fun game
right but listen i've got everything
exactly the way it should be right
everything so we've got the [ __ ]
sauce special dick and sauce you can get
that on amazon no you can't you know
bezos you can't get it on amazon no no
why would you they don't have the
infrastructure for that you can only buy
this in supermarkets you can only buy it
in supermarkets only in quebec probably
get back yeah shout out to our friend up
north eric thanks buddy hey eric this
wouldn't have happened without eric i'm
telling you right now couple kalka shows
thanks for the dick sauce thank you
[ __ ] yes as is a very thin burger
but it's like like a like um what are
those things you used to put in
computers so they did so dick
a floppy disk right so you could put
this in a computer remember computers
guys they used to have things called
floppy disks do you know why dickens
makes a thin burger
no teeth
some teeth little soft teeth speed and
efficiency speed and efficiency they
only cared about two things they cared
about efficiency
and quality sounds like dick knew what
he was doing exactly and
two he came up with the idea a thin
patty burger cooks faster right right
hey but a thin patty burger and a thin
bun
goes even faster
same time yeah they broke up faster at
the same time same time together i don't
know faster than faster than the other
burger better than the faster the speed
of dick sauce faster look at this
a burger cooks this fast and it's done
that is nice color
they look like little pancakes there's
more color on that side more color on
this side yes yes chef yes chef george
okay so look at this also true to form
at [ __ ] is a two ounce patty that
is a thin little
two nothing to it that's it right that's
it look at that look at that look at
this
it looks like a
hat a burger legacy burger it's but it's
look it's paper looking i don't know
it's paper thin
oh [ __ ]
where's the little plate
and this is the the main feature yes
yeah oh yeah don't judge don't blow it
okay don't blow it yet
don't blow it
that's their commercial see look what's
happening here i'm excited
this looks very familiar to you right
yeah
now you're getting that little dirty
cooked looks like a bologna cup i think
it was just like that's that thing was
on there for 30 seconds it's done
already okay patty goes on the bun right
daddy goes on the bus that's cheese they
use swiss cheese not american cheese
swiss well they're french
fries why would you serve america now
right now doesn't you put the sauce on
right you know the sauce right just
enough i don't know i feel like that's a
lot that's oh it should be more than
that i think right you think it's
dripping
a little more
there you go good okay
okay ready here we go you're a saucepan
onions onions
raw onions
what's the difference between hot dog
relish and hamburger relish nothing
nothing
it's like only facts that's right are
there aliens do you believe in aliens
ghosts i'm a ghost man okay mutard okay
mustard there is one final touch we did
the one can you grab the here we go now
this is what really makes it this see
this
how do you get that off of that it's a
plate on top of a plate how do you how
do you get your little hands under there
can't there's no way you're like you're
[ __ ] you're fibbling you're falling
apart i can't eat it what do i do oh yes
that's right you buy 100 little wooden
spoons you need to
yeah right
exactly did you hear that you lost me
this is iconic yes if you go to dick
anne's yeah they serve it just like that
it's a wedge it's a survivor it's a
reverend
which is basically french for stick
lifter lifter
sliver
and it's literally there to lift the
burger off you should make a mini one
you know your little spatula yeah you
should make a lifter
and see the sauce that goes on top it's
melted this is beautiful look at that
and this is is it authentic let me get
my cheeseburger
oh
thank you
every canadian right now is what dude
right i'm trying to see what this is
aside right here here we go uh-huh
you tell me
he's smiling at me
that's good
that's good
and the thing that is good about it
is everything
[Music]
it's just like dude have you had this
yet you haven't had it i'm going to say
what just happened what just happens you
went back
back in time
matrix
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's in my um
hmm
oh [ __ ]
hmm
that's good burger
[Music]
that's good is that good the greater of
the parts well together entirely
quebecois right
george couples
hey celebrate boutard colorado
and that's the magic of food and
friendship and unity and life and love
everything that this man does
brings light and love into the world
once again the ripples that this man
sets forward with burgers is astounding
every single time this man puts effort
towards something gold
you're welcome
hey thanks for watching burger scholar
sessions you should like and subscribe
to this channel but also get more
episodes up here
somewhere in here right there
yeah watch more episodes right here